hello everyone and welcome back to
game review as always my name is caleb
denby and today i want to walk you
through
how pre-arranged draws have some
negative side effects that you might not
expect
on the game of chess of course it's a
controversial topic pre-arranged
draws but perhaps the funniest thing to
ever
come come out of these prearranged draws
is what happened to vichy anand
so let's take a look here first at not
vishyanan's game
this is a very interesting game between
anthony j
miles and larry mark christensen uh
larry christensen of course
you know american chess legend uh this
game goes e4
e5 knight f3 knight f6
knight takes e5 d6 knight f3
knight takes e4 and knight c3 so far so
normal
this is probably the most popular line
against the petrov at the top level
today
generally here black can retreat the
knight or capture on c3
and we're gonna get an interesting game
where white has some rapid development
and looks to castle queen's side and
apply some pressure to black's king
in this game though larry christensen
shows the rather
interesting move bishop to f5
and uh the game continued fairly
normally we saw
knight takes e4 bishop takes e4 d3
and both players develop the pieces they
sort of trade at every opportunity
rookie one rookie eight queen d2 even
the knights come off the board
and eventually we see the rooks and
lastly uh the game is agreed to a drop
before they even get the chance to trade
the queens
and so if you're a top level player
it's sort of is pre-computery era i
think computers are around but they're
not exactly what they are today
and let's say you're vishy not and you
see this game and you're like wow
that looked like a really easy game for
black i want some of that
in my chess games well that's how you
end up
with uh this game between alonzo zapata
and vichy and not this is the exact same
position
on move five vichy seeing larry play
this bishop f5 move
says hey why don't i try some of that
and of course
white now has a winning tactic here so
you at home
pause the video see if you can find how
to win
uh a full piece and kind of even more
uh in one single move here so hopefully
you found it of course the idea is the
simple move queen to e2
pinning the knight to the king and
applying more pressure
and at first glance it might not seem
like it's all that bad
uh of course if black plays some sort of
naive move like d5 we're gonna hit him
with d3
attacking the pinned piece and winning
the material
but you might think why not just queen
to e7 sort of defending this knight
outright
and it looks as if you know there's
there's no serious problems yet
well once again we need another clever
move to win the game
go ahead and try to find it at home
otherwise here it is
it's the move knight d5 uh the classic
removal of the defender
and we're going to follow up with d3
next this queen simply cannot both
unpin the knight and defend the c7
square so black would have to move out
of the way
and again now we get d3 and are winning
a full piece
so uh this is why
pre-arranged draws can have some uh
unintentional consequences here
uh and i believe there's a story go
floating around on the internet about
the game between larry christensen and
anthony miles
and that is that uh anthony miles spent
a lot of time
cleaning off the e2 square adjusting it
with this finger to make sure there was
no dust there
just to show larry the folly he had made
but miles stuck to the pre-arranged
agreement
and they drew that game ending up in
vichy losing
in just six moves how embarrassing
as always thank you guys so much for
tuning in for this episode of
game review my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time